now in each of these cases simply to
remember back what's brackets me always
I can't emphasize enough please do not
just it okay this is the step I have to
do now who knows why it's just the step
and then my aides I mention anything
with evaporable don't do that
remember brackets are just done saying
okay everything that you see inside the
brackets do that to it just take
whatever the thing is at the front and
apply it now one of the things you need
to remember is that again because
mathematicians are famously lazy lots of
things are actually missing from here
it's so much shorthand in you sometimes
we forget it's there for instance first
thing there's multiplication there right
so this is 5x take away five times all
that and if you remember that it's not
that difficult to expand asleep you're
gonna do it once twice and then you can
do some simplifying watch nothing's
gonna happen to this 5x it's just
hanging out the front they're not
affected by the practice the first
pairing is minus 5 times 2x do it the
numbers 5 times 2 of course is 10 and
the minus sign comes along for the right
along with the X ok so I've done that
bit I have one more time left in the
brackets rights on 1 minus 5 times 1
which is
okay now remember I said look
disappointed
the reason why is because the 5x of the
minus 10x online - so I can collect them
what I'm gonna get will be simply write
5x takeaway 10x what do you get left
with my minus 5x right just cuz the
order matters in subtract so minus 5x
take away 5 and it son that's as simple
as it's going to get so the same way
it's have a good time this you have to
be watchful because of the double
negative
yeah so again the takeaway 6 subtract
see that's what's going to apply to
everything in the bank it's ready so 8
take away 6 times 3x which is how many X
since my 318 and then when you take away
6 lots off taking away - its plus truck
right one last time you can see white
terms are revealed out by expanding so I
can collect them yah-hey plus 12 gives
me 20 and now last one I'm just going to
show you then we'll move on to
substitution like I said this shorthand
right this one's double shorthand
because not only is there a price tag in
there
it doesn't even tell you what you're
multiplying by there's a 1 there
right minus 1 is the number it gets
multiplied by each of these sorry each
of these terms right so again you get
double menu as we confusing but it's
just we common right you don't need to
say one X or one pie you just say X
whatever nothing you have so now that
you know that you can do the expansion
can someone tell me he's already done
this question yeah Victoria can you help
me turn to an answer can you tell me
what this next step is
yeah it's all around yeah
very good okay so you can see just like
in the previous one guys now that
there's that double negative one lot 2x
and there's a - once you simplify out
how many X's are left
just one poster minutes